you could see the back of his head while
he was leaving
the gate like he was running you know
we're like ah like scatter scatter
scatter so
my mom sees the back of his head mind
you my mom doesn't know that i have a
boyfriend
doesn't know what's going on sees the
back of his head she's like get
your [ __ ] ass in this house
right now oh my god that's just so scary
and my mom
never hit me yeah but i knew i was
[ __ ]
yeah so go in in five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain
podcast uh this is a very special
episode because
we have my hawaiian crush on here today
we have
nikki blades probably one of my favorite
radio personalities
a woman with brains and beauty nikki
blaze is in the house everybody thank
you
man i have been wanting to be here first
off
i was super upset when you did the
podcast
with tim during quarantine uh-huh and i
wasn't there
i was so mad because i had already been
a fan right like
everybody that's in the no chaser circle
and jk news
and just in general right so i've been
infiltrating as i said i've been
infiltrating your guys's group
yeah and when quarantine hit i couldn't
come down
everything had to be filmed at tim's
house yeah
tim was like you're not coming i was
like i'm not traveling i'm not leaving
we all got to be safe this was
we were super serious about it but then
when you went on i was like
nikki's because you're intimidating okay
i was like you're intimidating as [ __ ]
you want to go and be on the podcast
when i'm not there and then it was like
okay so
when are you going to come back and that
was the whole question was like how am i
going to get in the same room with this
man
i'm going to come on send foods i'm
going to just start inviting myself to
episodes
though like you could ask all my friends
like when i when i was a kid literally i
love hawaii right so i
this is the first year i haven't been
back to hawaii in 10 years
wow so i go twice a year that's how much
i love life right
the people the culture the food i mean i
don't know if i could live there per se
you know what i'm saying like especially
because we moved out here things are
popping it's a little different right
but i remember when i saw a photo you i
was like
if my like young high school david had a
picture of a girl that he wanted to be
with it was nikki blades
and i was like yo my [ __ ] 15 year old
self right now is tripping
you know and i'm like and then i was
like oh what ethnicity is she was like
where are you from he's like she's from
hawaii i'm getting the [ __ ] out of here
right now
yeah what the [ __ ] is going on you know
i'm not like yo mario hold on a second
real quick
hi how are you that's nuts so you grew
up in hawaii yes
so i'm from oahu uh makakilo is where my
dad is from and where
where i grew up i left when i was about
six and then i moved to
a small town called newman okay central
valley
not out here when you ever say the
valley to anybody from la or that lives
in l.a they're like uh the valley out
here i'm like no no [ __ ] where almonds
come from yeah
like the valley valley valley where
produce actually
comes from i grew up there had my 18th
birthday in a canal like
that's [ __ ] funny seriously grew up
out there um and then i would go back
and forth
from california to hawaii i didn't do
that until
i was out of college because i played
travel ball so i traveled the us playing
softball and volleyball oh
really yeah so i traveled playing
softball volleyball and that was from
since i was like eight i traveled the
united states
getting to play and that was my life
sports was my life then when i was done
i wanted to go back home a lot so i
would go back and forth to hawaii
there would be times oh my god my
ex-boyfriend used to hate it i would be
like i'm going back home they're like
what we would fight and i would hop a
flight to hawaii
wow go back and my parents really loved
that
we connected with going back home my
parents didn't go home a lot
and now they still live in newman
they're still out there okay but i
haven't been home
i want to say in a couple years because
the last time i went was for a funeral
and it was really tough because that's
paradise for a lot of people but that's
still home
and you still got to deal with home
issues and those things don't go away
but i feel like once the pandemic is
chilled out i don't want to be
disrespectful and go home and
bring that to the island like a lot of
people kind of just blatantly
did during the pandemic because they
just wanted to go to hawaii yeah
um i'm waiting until stuff is a little
bit better i got friends back there
trying to get me to come back home
i miss it do you would you can you ever
see yourself moving back no
okay that was fast well the rest of this
podcast guys
no but but living living in hawaii right
now
would not make sense for what i want in
life oh yeah 100
uh do i see myself going back eventually
i always see myself having multiple
homes i would love to get homestead i
would love to have something that my
family can go to i'd love to have a
place that my dad
my mom my nieces you know my family
could go that's the goal
own land in hawaii so that my family can
go
and we're ultimately fighting for land
in a sense you know like everybody's
coming in and buying so why wouldn't i
want to do that
um but i really got to be where the
money's at and the goal is to
be wherever that is yeah and hopefully
that could be in hawaii but i don't see
myself just being there
how many years were you in hawaii before
you moved over to the mainland six
six okay yeah but then i grew up hoy
like
everyday hoy the i moved you know what
was [ __ ] when i was on no chaser
you started doing the [ __ ] pigeon you
started
i can call my dad right now like my dad
and i are so close
that he is the epitome of what i think
of as like
local boy yeah local is like a moke like
just kind of no
actually my dad is they would call him
like more of the city boy my dad is more
city boy he was definitely oahu was in
the night life my dad is six two green
eyes you know
he was the pretty boy yeah um my sisters
i still have sisters that are out there
they call me city girl
oh okay i am not a mok i'm not country
but my mom
my mom is from pearl city okay so my mom
used to
scrap my mom was not the one she's the
titter with the [ __ ] the butt on top
my mom is not the one and my aunt you
know my aunt at
um actually just recently moved from
hawaii and lived with my parents now
so my mom's sister my auntie uh renee
lives with my mom and my dad and it's so
different because i went from when i was
young living in a house full of hawaiian
so
when we moved from hawaii to the
mainland it was like
13 of us in a house yeah right like i
used to live
uh at one point in time my parents were
living in a makeshift room in the garage
and i was living on the side of the
house with my sister you know they would
build out like they
had a house and they built rooms
you know essentially i was sleeping next
to the kitchen growing up
yeah and like the floor was the cement
outside and they would have to go and
pat it and you know that's that's how we
grew up
and growing up local style is very
different than you know
you leave your house and i'm hanging out
with my friends that are like from
modesto or
in the valley and they just have no idea
what i'm talking about like yeah they
don't get
that [ __ ] is crazy in the house at all
times like
barbecuing on the corner fights on the
corner uh 13 cars 17 people going in
another house
i would tell people about about this and
people don't understand and i and i told
the story when
i was in hawaii and the about the fight
culture there yeah right
and you know there's there's waikiki
and like the main city area right that's
different like that's not
that's not local [ __ ] like i've seen
local dudes scrap like it's nothing
and then they'll [ __ ] go and have a
beer after yes and i've never seen some
[ __ ] like that in my life
that shouldn't scare the [ __ ] out of me
i'm talking about i was at a bar and
this dude was like you got beef bro
and i'm like this [ __ ] about to
cook something yeah what's happening
right and these days
go outside of the bar they start
scrapping like throwing down
i'm like are these [ __ ] ufc fighters
yeah but these guys can scrap
beats the [ __ ] out of this dude it's
actually a pretty close fight but he
cracked him real hard i don't know what
the [ __ ] it was i was drunk as [ __ ]
and they come in he's like you good
brother he's like yeah he goes he buys
them a beer and they squash it and they
move i'm like
what the [ __ ] just happened yeah you
know i was super aggressive for a long
time like
really really aggressive and mind you i
tell people that i'm one of the nicest
ones in my family
like i am the nice one i'm the sensitive
i'm the crybaby i'm emotional i was
very much picked on and i didn't know
how to express my feelings because you
you also know you're not allowed to talk
back there is no i had no feelings yeah
you
you do daddy this is how i felt what the
[ __ ] is feeling
no i was the i'm the sensitive crybaby
one um but
my mom taught me how to throw punches
like real early like she would put a
piece of paper on the wall and i knew
how to through punches that's the most
ghettoest thing i've ever had in my life
piece of paper my mom my mom's [ __ ] is
[ __ ]
ghetto your [ __ ] put a piece of
paper
and practice yeah practice throwing
punches
my mom got into a lot of fights in
hawaii yeah
a lot and like you were saying fight
culture is real you fight if you pretty
you fight if you go to the wrong school
you fight if you're in the wrong place
at the wrong time you fight
yeah and you gotta know how to fight
that was it
and part of the reason why they took us
from hawaii and brought us out into a
small small small controlled environment
in a town with two stop signs there
weren't even stop lights in the town i
grew up in okay that's [ __ ] crazy
yes and that my parents still live out
there and i still always show newman
love like
my family is still out there i go back
as much as possible to see you know
spend time with them but
growing up my mom didn't want us to deal
with the same things
yeah my mom used to have to make a
decision every day
am i gonna take the school bus and go to
school or the city bus
and go to the beach every day she would
make a decision
what do i feel like doing and my dad was
more straight laced than my mom was as
far as like
education upbringing things like that so
it's a good balance when we had moved to
california
but my parents wanted the best for me
they did not want
me to have to deal with the same things
that they dealt with yeah
just the everyday like go you have to
fight
and if you didn't know how to fight you
get your ass beat and then if you get
your ass beat
when you're out and you come home you're
going to get your ass beat because you
got your ass beat
that i think that was like the funniest
thing too i feel like when you grow up
with like these very like
apparently very similar right yeah it's
like when i was a kid i used to get
bullied a lot and so but my dad wouldn't
like the fact that somebody would bully
me
so he goes well if they just say words
to you let them say words but if they
touch you
right do something about it got it so i
got into a lot of trouble right because
i was a geeky little fat
kid but then my dad i had korean rage
and so they would like touch
so i would literally just say a word and
i and you know the principal and the
teachers caught on is like you got to
stop
fighting because i started becoming a
provocateur because i'd be like
hey just touch me right because i want
to get my ass beat at home
yeah because they would be the first one
to attack right but they caught on real
quick it's like you're just saying that
so you could beat them up yeah you know
and so my dad so i would get into a
fight and you know per my dad's advice
i would come back home he goes you got
into a fight and then i get my ass beat
i'm like yo this is a lose-lose
situation
yeah when i was going when i was in
school i definitely wasn't starting no
fights i wasn't i stayed out of trouble
a lot i was super super super square
like
really couldn't do anything up until i
was done with high school my dad was
very very strict
they had goals my parents left hawaii
and they put goals
as far as they wanted me to graduate
high school they didn't want me to have
a baby
at 16 like a lot of the people in my
family did and just like a lot of the
culture in hawaii is you go
and make babies you make babies
everybody got hella kids yeah
you know like everybody got kids and you
go beach and it's very family oriented
which is what i love about our cultures
family is the foundation for everything
with like i was talk
grow grew up with so much respect for
elders and my aunts and my uncles and
really loving the everybody's auntie
everybody's auntie uncle so even to this
day when i say certain things like my
friends their kids i'm auntie
because you're not going to be
disrespectful you're not going to call
me by my by my name who the [ __ ]
you are not no no no no yeah i am anti
and i will treat you like you're my
niece and once you're in that
realm like that's my baby i always want
to take care of
you know the kids and that's one thing i
took away from it but growing up
it like the [ __ ] you see you realize
it's not normal
right like people fighting over the
dumbest [ __ ] is not normal
people yelling all the time just yell is
not normal
it shouldn't be okay you know um the the
fights i've seen people go through walls
i've seen you know uncles throw somebody
through a door like
yo man that's like the the funny thing
is but that's what
so many people if i complain you know
like my cousins we could all sit here
and we will
laugh because we're the only ones that
get it yeah let me tell you something
when i went to college right
and you know there's like this moment
when you're in the dorm room and you're
sharing these stories right
and you know i'm with the riverside
riverside wasn't uh it wasn't
academically really known for smart
people like i got it you know i mean
like i got into the [ __ ] school
right i don't even apply to riverside
like you're in like they just need
people thank you just please come back
please come in right but then a lot of
these kids who lived in los angeles
they went to riverside because it was
close to home and they got full-ride
scholarships
right because they were just handing
them out because they needed people who
were academically really successful
to come to this school so i remember
just like sharing these like family
stories and i'm thinking people can
relate
right you know then you realize and i
told the story and you know i'm laughing
about this and i remember i looked
around the room and everybody was
mortified i was like yo man i had this
one uncle he got so mad at me he threw
his butcher knife and he barely missed
my nose
and everybody's like dead quiet i'm like
oh y'all don't have that
no i'm like well i mean well okay
they're like
you know you can let us know if it's
still happening are you okay you could
stay over at our house
my dad used to tell
people he hit me my dad used to tell
people
and he used to tell people there was no
like it was what it was our family
growing up in a small town hawaiian
south i grew up hawaiian every day there
was not
a day i wasn't hawaiian i'm very very
very proud of being hawaiian i love my
culture
i love you know who we are and what
they've given me
but growing up in a small town being the
hawaiian girl
to woody's daughter it was what i was
noticing everybody knew who my dad was
my dad made
it very very known that if my daughter
[ __ ] up
and you're there and you see it and you
don't tell me
and we're friends i'm coming for you wow
so i used to get snitched out for the
dumbest [ __ ] like
i had a real problem with the town that
i grew up in for a long time because i
hated
how people were so afraid and they
didn't realize that it was [ __ ] up my
[ __ ] like if i just want to be a normal
kid and i want to go downtown and get
pizza by the way downtown is a walk from
the school it's
literally two stop signs like it's not a
big
town people used to snitch me out to my
dad
and the thing was is like if somebody
saw me i never knew what i was coming
home to
god damn i never knew what was gonna
happen
and a big thing that my dad always
always was don't embarrass me
and there was nothing worse than him
finding out about me doing something
and me not being the one telling him are
you korean
that's like some korean [ __ ] when we
were when you were on the podcast
and you were saying certain things i'm
like yeah that's i get it because it was
always like
do you know how that makes me look right
not like how it makes us feel
oh my god you know the i went to
a club it was a 18 and under it was like
a 16 and up club you know one of those
little things it was in modesto
we had a joint it was called polari out
in sacramento yeah so so we had one in
modesto and i remember we were at one of
our
family friend's house my dad's friend's
house and the daughter i had a boyfriend
at the time my dad didn't know modesto
is trash by the way
outside yo that place is ghetto dude
like you know it's get like i'm talking
about
like i knew some terrible terrible human
beings
and they were out in stockton in modesto
shadow stockton i did radio out there
and let me tell you something i heard it
got a lot better but yeah and there's
still spots that are really bad
but literally like in an area where
there's nothing else to do there's only
[ __ ] dirt that's
right it's literally you got to do dirt
just to have fun one of my home uh one
of my homeboys as a police officer out
there had seen that i was into
actually i went to go get pho and he was
uh i went by myself
and it was nighttime but i wasn't
thinking nothing of it i'm like i'm just
gonna go running and get some [ __ ] he
actually was working and
he saw me mind you no i don't live in
modesto
he got out of his cop car and was like
you cannot go out by yourself and i was
like what he goes look i just spotted
you i knew exactly who you were he goes
it's not safe like you cannot be moving
around by yourself you know it's scary
man like there was let me tell you this
like so i
had a homie right and like we've we've
been friends for for a minute right and
i knew he wasn't a great person i don't
like the [ __ ] that he did but he was
always nice to me right cause i was a
funny goofy dude people just like to
have me around
right like i always said this i was
around people who were really bad i was
just i just never did bad things yeah
they always were very protective of me
but i remember i went to
go pick something up at his house and i
get there i had this like busted ass
[ __ ] like isuzu trooper like this old
car i get there
and i remember i closed the door i lock
it i walked to the door i [ __ ] you
[ __ ] and i'm not making this up i
turn around and there's like
eight people next to my car i'm like and
my homie comes out he goes
he's good he just dispersed like
cockroaches i'm like yeah
yo where the [ __ ] am i like what the
[ __ ] is going on he goes oh
my whole family is on this whole [ __ ]
cul-de-sac so when a car comes through
that they don't
recognize they want to see who you are
they want to see what's up right and i
was like did they come out of the sewage
like where the [ __ ] did these
[ __ ] go does it even seem real
right yeah i was like yo where did they
come from they just all came out from
the house and went to go see what's up i
was like oh [ __ ]
man my cousin so i got five girl cousins
five girl cousins that are [ __ ]
badasses
let me tell you yeah you don't want the
smoke
as i said i'm the nice one of the family
i'm the most like
i want to say my sister is actually very
well tempered my sister my sister is a
she's an [ __ ] yeah but she's way more
confident than i've
ever was smarter like her comeback she
my sister's
meticulous right she don't have to hurt
you physically
but my cousins they're all of it
combined they'll chop you down with
their words and
they got four other sisters that will
beat you up like dave literally
like it's a phone call i need you to be
here
showing up like it is like surrounding
you got the
part you blocked that door you are on
this side you're over there like let's
go
my cousins are right or die beautiful
though
beautiful but will [ __ ] you up like you
don't want to play with them
and like i said i'm the nice one of the
family but i also know that if i ever
have to call
you don't ever want me to have to call
what was the last time you got into like
a fight
oh god forever nah i'm good i think when
i was working in the club that's like
the main thing i was always
i never had to square up on anybody in a
long
long long long time that's like a final
last resort type [ __ ] but
when i was working in the club because i
did bottle service so
i got my first nightlife you know job at
21 three days after my 21st birthday
okay
went out to club aqua in modesto doing
hood rat [ __ ] with my friend
shout out nancy love you girl club aqua
so i went to club aqua
about a place i enjoyed uh-huh i
actually ended up
working there's a lot of bunch of
[ __ ] asian gang bangers there dude
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] thuggish
thuggish right so that should just tell
you a little bit about me
that's where my first like yeah you see
a lot
yeah been through a lot but got my first
nightlife job three days after my 21st
birthday i remember manny
one of the managers at the club had seen
me with my girl you know we're drinking
and whatnot and he was like you ever
thought about doing bottle service i'm
like i'm sorry sir what are you talking
about no i don't know what that is
uh and he's like you want a job mind you
i knew a little bit about nightlife
because my parents
actually used to work the clubs in
hawaii yeah my dad was one of the like
main security and bouncers and did a lot
of uh
private security stuff out there my mom
actually was a bartender back in the day
so it's in our blood right so i took
that job and i was out in modesto but
being out there and in the club scene um
you learn how to defend yourself and
plus my dad put me up on a lot of [ __ ] i
my dad used to walk past me and i used
to have to block him he used to
purposely try to smack me so that i
would have my spidey senses
that is a fascinating human being my dad
yes my dad
my dad used to walk around when we were
sitting mind you i used to do dips while
i watched tv because i was training
because i played travel sports so i
would always be working out everything
was an opportunity to either learn or to
work out or to just get better
right so my dad's like what happens if
somebody tries to attack you so we used
to do like
you know hand stuff you know your ears
can come off you know your eyes come out
you poke them in the nose if you hit
somebody in the head
what they're gonna do like where the
head goes the body follows so
i was trained my whole life
so when i got into the club i'm already
just socking customers in the face for
no reason senses
were always on a thousand right i knew
all my exits
this is the type of [ __ ] i would think
about before entering any room i knew
every exit i knew all my security guards
i knew what to do just in case some [ __ ]
went down i knew who to trust and who
not to trust
but it was bad like security
always had to follow me like guys had
the cameras they always have to watch
because guys would go and grab my ass
men would go like i'm walking through
the club because i'm doing bottle
service you're wearing like a
swimsuit a body suit you're in like i'm
half naked running around the club
and guys would try and grab me little
did they know i wasn't the one that you
would want to try to grab because i
would grab them back
and i used to snatch dudes up and hold
them while security comes and gets them
oh my god this makes you strong
so like it was it was to the point to my
last job i was i was working in san
francisco
at a temple and security cameras
always knew and i had to have particular
security guards around me because
i don't think people realize how stupid
people are when they drink how dumb and
the lack of like
respect that people have for each other
goes out the window
i've had guys try to slip their hand
underneath
like and when i tell you i turn around
i've definitely
punched people in the back of the head
yo i'm trying to figure it out
like what was the move guy like what was
gonna happen
when you did that on every night there
would be a different occasion so i never
had to fight people or get into
arguments i mean the last time i really
like i said had to fight somebody
was a long time ago but i was constantly
ready that that's how i always felt that
i was always on edge because
people were so disrespectful guys
blatantly would try to grab your ass
or try to grab your hand or try to pull
you and
you have to establish yourself as
someone not to [ __ ] with because they
will try to [ __ ] with you so many of
these guys would go out
and they would look for drunk girls or
they would try to fill up on their butts
or things like that but little do they
know i got a long ass reach
yo i just had this funny ass image of a
dude trying to grab your ass
right and then you literally lift him up
in the middle of the air he's just like
oh my god like why is this [ __ ] so
strong is this a man
what i've had when i've had people like
look at the security guards like help me
i'm like
if you don't get him i will security
used to be like
you better get the guy out before nicki
gets to him because i'm not going to
stop
yeah i was like this i do not tolerate
that type of [ __ ] and i wasn't scared
did you ever have like
co-workers who were doing bottle service
that would just like take it
yeah yeah we've had that you know i've
been in the management position to where
you got to learn how to handle these
situations you properly have to train
people you have to let them know like
hey you can't let them do this right
and you and then you also have to be
aware of when that happens how are you
going to react you know
um if you're working for a business and
some this is a real slimy part about a
lot of it is that
some people will overlook like the girls
saying that like this person was
disrespectful they grabbed me and just
be like because they're spending so much
money
they just let it go they just let it go
yeah and i do love that where i've
worked and the people i've worked with
when i say somebody touched me
inappropriately
they knew i wasn't just lying and that
i was more important than the sleaze
ball and that's
really it sucks because not every woman
is like that
and not everybody's being trained to
defend themself right
the only reason why i was always ready
was because i was taught to be ready
yeah and a lot of people get caught off
guard by it and that's why it's so
violating well chris for you earlier
when we were talking off on the podcast
for like an hour but
you were talking about like you uh you
had a moment where you realized that you
were attractive because before
yeah you didn't you didn't realize that
what was that moment for you college
okay well let me tell you i didn't
realize i was good looking to college oh
my god like i again
in my family you
i got picked on by my family like by my
family
it was we were all pinned against each
other i felt like the adults
growing up were and thoroughly
entertained by
the there was like eight girls you know
and it was always a competition
everything is about looks or dancing
everything was entertainment i danced
hula i was on stage
all this stuff but my cousins
also were very attractive early on i was
goofy [ __ ] looking for a long
time like i was ugly
insert photo he was like you know uh
when i look at it
now i wasn't ugly but in during that
time and what it felt like and i was
super super you know i was in the sun
playing baseball all the time so i had
ugly ass tan lines i had really bad acne
i was in a town where there was nobody
else that looked like me
yeah nobody i graduated with less than
100 people at my school
jesus right uh i didn't get asked to
prom
i didn't get asked to prom everybody was
afraid of my dad
uh well yeah you didn't get asked about
because your dad was [ __ ] frightening
as [ __ ] who the [ __ ] would want to ask
you the problem that's like a death wish
yes terrifying so i didn't get asked my
senior prom my dad actually had to help
me
find my date for my senior prom and he
had to threaten them actually not that's
a different story but i'll tell you
about that and that backfired on dad
that ended up
working out well for me but uh growing
up i just didn't look like anybody else
and i recently saw somebody say
uh were you actually ugly growing up or
did you just grow up around people who
didn't look like you
yeah the reality of it was is i really
wasn't ugly it's just i was different
there was no other i'm mixed i'm
hawaiian chinese filipino and irish
the [ __ ] and people didn't know what i
was i have curly hair i was
really really dark growing up and they
just were like what are you and of
course because i don't look like the
standard
i was picked on nobody wanted to date me
i just felt very left out and then my
cousins
i felt were more conventionally pretty i
didn't look like anybody in my family
either so on top of it i'm looking
around like i am
the goofy looking kid out of the pretty
bunch
yeah so when i got to college
and college was real diverse you got
guys from
all over i didn't know what a
light skin or like exotic looking you
know i didn't know what exotic
was yeah until i got to college and when
i got to college
i was that [ __ ] i was that [ __ ]
period but i walked around and i knew it
though i had
the [ __ ] attitude i was a you know
softball and volleyball i played
softball and volleyball in college was
recruited to play basketball as well
i could skateboard i was exceptionally
well like good at sports i used to tell
invite all the teams to come watch me
play
because i just was so confident like i
was so confident
and the stage was the field for me or
the court
and i showed off that's where i've
always felt myself is in an athletic
environment yeah
so when i got to college and i was
getting all this attention it wasn't
just because i was good and this was the
first time that i was on a team
and playing with people not because i
you know like they had to fill a quota
like i'm supposed to be on this field
when i was playing travel ball i was the
broke brown girl
i was the i was the poor girl on the
team and my dad used to have to cook
in order for us to be able to afford to
play
or and a lot of the times when you're
doing it it's politics
so this was the first time that i was
where i was supposed to be and where i
was you know
but good felt great i tell you this
there's nothing that feels better than
hitting a home run and hearing people
cheer for you
and having like everybody in the stands
like that's
nikki you know yeah yeah and so when i
was in college i was
in my zone and that's when i found out
that i was attractive because i started
realizing how people
acted you know not only had i been goofy
dudes just opened up doors
for no [ __ ] reason it was like whoa
what it like it really
felt like what is this yeah this
attention which is partially why you
shouldn't be super super strict to your
daughters because they're gonna get to
college and realize oh i could do
whatever the [ __ ]
i want and i do whatever
here we go and i did whatever the [ __ ] i
wanted to do because my dad was super
super strict so
uh that's when i found out and i really
came into my own i actually started
modeling
after i was done playing ball okay and i
had always wanted to model though
uh but in the modeling industry being
attractive isn't necessarily
what models are yeah that's not what
you're you're not there because you're
the prettiest girl in the room
being a model doesn't that doesn't mean
that you have to fit a look you're
a hanger you know it's a looking
different is good
so even when i knew i could model when i
was younger it wasn't because i was the
prettiest girl
and then getting into college and the
confidence and
seeing how people reacted to me and then
already being a dorky goofy person and
having a personality because you develop
a personality when you're
goofy yeah yeah uh that's kind of when i
started combining the two worlds right
like okay
i'm good-looking by what everybody's
telling me not just because i was
feeling myself and i'm the [ __ ]
um and then adding the personality in
and then all the things that made me
me you had like this overprotective
father right so what was your what was
your first kiss
before we continue with this podcast
let's talk about our amazing
sponsor i p vanish if you are browsing
the internet
right now without a virtual private
network have you lost your stupid stupid
mind
everybody is seeing your [ __ ] you need
to get
ipvanish you can use a vpn on your
computers tablets phones and even things
like your fire stick when you're
streaming media when you use
a vpn all your data is encrypted
what you're reading what you're
searching what you're watching whatever
it
is you're doing here's everything you
get with ipvanish anonymous ip addresses
you can circumvent any online censorship
get protection
while using public wi-fi and remember
with ipvanish all your data is encrypted
so no one can snoop on what you're doing
so go to ipvanish.combrain
claim your 65 savings they have plans
starting at 349 a month or 27.99 a year
this is the time to sign up with our
discount and their current promotional
offerings
you can get a vpn for 65 off the usual
offering
ipvanish is the best of the best even
rated 4.7 out of 5
on trustpilot and that's more than 6 000
reviews show these guys some love
remember it's ipvanish.com
brain to get the deal and start
protecting yourself
online junior high snuck it
i snuck it okay it was um after
basketball practice
i remember i remember it was after
basketball practice and everything had
to revolve around uh the sports schedule
because that's the only gaps that you
can get right
shout out to all the parents that housed
me uh because they knew my dad was crazy
like legit uh but my first kiss was in
junior high
and it was after a basketball practice
and it was like a real quick
sneaky sneak kiss okay yeah and then
that was it everything was revolved
around
everyone knew my dad everybody knew my
dad was crazy
and everybody also knew my dad didn't
give a [ __ ] there's a level to like oh
you're intimidating but when you just
don't give a [ __ ]
my dad did not give a [ __ ] it's
terrifying
uh he because you had your first kiss in
junior high
and your dad was like this helicopter
dad right yeah so when did you lose your
virginity because in between those whole
times is
a frightening experience terrified so my
boyfriend which i my dad knows i had a
boyfriend in high school i told him a
couple years ago
and we actually sat down i was like by
the way dad i had a boyfriend in high
school he was like i kind of figured and
put two and two
together when i started noticing a six
foot something guy that didn't go to the
same school as you showing up at some of
these games sitting in the back
i dated this guy from delhi
which is a town that's about 30 minutes
away from where i lived but it was in
the same
district so we played against each other
schools and i remember
freshman year of high school i never
seen a guy dunk before
they were running they were running
court mind you i am an athlete so the
way that we view what's attractive
normally is along the lines of the pro
you know what you're doing yeah so this
guy he was six foot four
their whole team they were running
practices you know they were running
balls and all those things he had no
shirt on and he ducked the ball and i
literally looked to the person next to
me and i was like
that one that's like nikki there's a
puddle where you were sitting
i wanted these oh my god i
just from i remember it oh and there was
like three they were all
friends i just never seen like guys that
look like that before he was just like
the most attractive man i've ever seen
but here's the funny part
that same day my friend well one of the
girls that i went to school with an
elementary school
actually transferred to the school that
they were at yeah
and i had seen her and we played in band
together okay
it was like yeah i played trumpet i was
in band and i
loved it too i don't care i loved band
okay and
i'd seen her and her name was patty and
i was like patty
we just started talking i was like yo
who's
that and she was like oh that's you know
that's so-and-so and i'm like
i need to meet him i just seen him and i
was like
i need to meet him and so she arranged
for us to meet
we talked we exchanged numbers my
freshman year of high school and
for a year and a half we spoke every day
we would sneak
to talk to each other on the phone i
actually we ended up dating like
we ended up getting together and a lot
of it was the sneaking my sister
definitely helped me with of course
of course um helped me to with the
sneaking of the phones and you know this
is house phones
yeah back when you had to grab both of
the phones at like
scheduling and timing them like he's
definitely called the house before and
pretended to be a girl
you know like all these get the [ __ ] out
yes hello
yes like oh my god and so your friends
are ugly
see he was a bigger dude so he was about
six four in high school holy [ __ ]
yeah so he so he was a bigger dude and
it was very upfront about how my dad was
so he knew what he was getting himself
into his family
knew and then uh one day i actually had
to tell my mom
about it and we snuck because she's like
don't tell your father
if we keep it between us i love my mom
because the only reason why
i had a life was because of her she knew
dad was crazy but she also knew why dad
was crazy dad did not want me to get
knocked up
that's how it was in hawaii yes and he
knew that there was a bigger plan for me
yeah one thousand percent my parents
always believed in me in anything i was
going to do but
i had to get there first yeah i used to
cry to my mom and be like mom i can't
take this like i can't do this this is
she's just like make it to 18 baby
let's make it to 18. just graduate just
graduate all you got to do is just
graduate keep doing what you're doing
it's going to be better out there
promise right that's how my mom was with
the comedy thing
she goes but it was more like i just
need you to graduate college and then
you could do whatever you want if you
want you just gotta just hold it and
just keep just keep going mom was like
i got you as long as you don't lie to me
and i need to know where you're going
and what you're doing
somebody has to know the truth yeah
about what you're doing
like somebody has to know because if
anything happens and you're lying
and we can't find you yeah it's on you
like
somebody has to always know what's going
on um we did the long distance thing
i would i ended up playing on a travel
team out there i picked i started
playing on like a shitty travel team out
in that town
i made friends with the girls that were
there like my best friend to this
day like two of my best friends are
actually from they went to school with
him that's funny
to this day because i used to stay at
their house their parents knew my dad
was
they knew and so there was so many
people that like
helped raise me to not be
completely sheltered and like not get to
live life
and i would stay at like a friend's
house and we get to see each other
or when uh my dad would do something or
i had a game like they would come it was
a lot of strategic planning to make this
happen but the one day
when my mom actually had to find out
about it was
still mad at my sister about this though
so he
came over okay my dad snores very very
loud
like my dad my dad's nurse he has like
sleep apnea and [ __ ] yes
so loud and that's how we were able to
maneuver around the phone
and to maneuver around getting out of
the house dad's snoring
you have to time it perfectly because
once you hear that yep
he's gonna wake up soon yeah consistent
snore we're good it's when it stops
right so i'm like chrissy he's gonna
come over because he's my sister's name
is like he's gonna come over we're gonna
be in the backyard now there's motion
sensors for the likes oh my god this is
from double 07. yeah
holy [ __ ] this is how we had to plan
because i would be dead yeah my dad
would have killed me
with no remorse he would have been like
you made me do it
you know yeah you made me do this so i'm
like all right chrissy
keep the lights on in the room we're
gonna act like it's you know it's
natural act natural the tv's going i'm
like this is what's happening i'm gonna
go into the back
dad's still sleeping if dad wakes up you
know the signal
go walk by the light the light's gonna
come on he's going to run out we got
this
it's [ __ ] hilarious yes man like i
cannot believe the shirt oh yeah
we were ready okay well i was ready so
he comes into the back so we're in the
backyard and the way that it's set up
it's kind of like so this is the main
house and
the backyard it's a little bit by like
the sign right yeah i still have time in
case need be and he could run
we had the latch on the gate to where in
case he needed to bolt out
we had it all set up right oh welp
so we're in the backyard chrissy decides
that she
just doesn't know what to say when mom
goes where's your sister
her face just told everything everything
so my mom comes bolts in the backyard
no time like no time bolts in the
backyard comes through
mind you he's six foot four
you could see the back of his head while
he was
leaving the gate like he was running
you know we're like ah like scatter
scatter scatter so my mom sees the back
of his head
mind you my mom doesn't know that i have
a boyfriend doesn't know what's going on
sees the back of his head she's like get
your [ __ ] ass
in this house right now oh my god that's
just so scary
and my mom never hit me yeah
but i knew i was [ __ ] yeah so
go in the house dad is still asleep
thank god
she sits me down she goes first off you
[ __ ] stink
because i smelt like him no who is that
and i'm bawling right i'm crying i'm
like oh [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] i'm done my mom actually
thought it was the guy that i had a
crush on in kindergarten she was like
was that so and so i was like oh my god
mom no no no no no
[ __ ] like yeah five years ago right
and i'm like mom no no it's not him
and she's just like who is it and this
is when the first conversation about
like sex and stuff had to happen with my
mom's mom's like
you have a [ __ ] like you got a [ __ ]
dude in the backyard do you not know
how stupid you are like you are [ __ ]
dumb your dad is going to kill you
who is this person i just remember
bawling and crying because i'd already
been in love with this guy this was like
the
my first love and i was crying i was
like mom this is that was so good i love
him and
i had like dogs have you ever seen a man
before it's
crazy he's so sweet he's so nice he's
smart he was i mean he was
smart he was athletic he was family
oriented these are
i thank god my first love had like
really good qualities i'm on to i'm on
to something here
and i just remember just blurting it all
out and just telling her like he's a
good guy i swear
his mom is great i've met his dad we've
been together for a long time
and i pulled out his um student id
because that was back when you like gave
each other your ids i remember i pulled
out the student id and i showed her
and she was like oh he's really
he's like really cute okay okay and my
mom just like
i just was bawling and i was crying and
she was like okay
now we have to have a talk yeah she goes
i don't want you to not
have a normal life she's like you do
deserve to be able to have a
relationship
but we got to set some rules and we got
to set some boundaries she's like also
your dad cannot find out about this
you cannot tell him that i know because
he's going to kill me
he's like once he finds out but i didn't
know [ __ ] i didn't know [ __ ] pretty much
is that that's
exactly what she said once in front of
him because i gotta play up the part
yes and so my mom was the reason why
i was able to have like a boyfriend and
to have like to get to experience a lot
of those things i didn't lose my
virginity until i was like 17 and a half
because he wanted yeah same guy he
wanted to wait
yeah he was i mean he really he really
was a good guy his family was so
understanding they knew how my dad was
and a lot of people around us knew that
i had a very strict
very very very strict dad and so the
people
he waited well you guys got to get when
you're 14. pretty much
damn dude what happened to him he
cheated on me when he because he was a
year older than me so when he got into
when he got into college uh because you
made him wait too long that's why
a lot of it had to do with because we
couldn't tell my dad oh yeah he would
have died he would have died and
so i mean i understand now looking back
i'm like totally like yo
i'm just even surprised you all dealt
with it this long but the funny part is
is that
i ran into his mom recently
with my dad oh wow yeah so
i ended up telling my dad about it who
he was
all you know the backstory and
everything but
his mom never liked my dad because she
always knew that he wasn't going to be
accepting of her son
exactly so it was a really strange
experience when they
saw each other because in my dad's head
he just was like oh
because he's a different person from
[ __ ] like yeah
you know he just was like oh hi yeah
sorry about what happened when they were
younger and whatever and i just
saw the look on his mom's face and i'm
just going i'm so
sorry just not in smile yeah you know
because
in her eyes she saw a lot of the [ __ ]
that we went through and i went through
and her son went through with us trying
to be together
yeah and we actually really did care
about each other and in my dad's eyes he
had no
idea but still is not sorry
so i was really gonna ask that like does
your dad ever regret
like how he was a little too strict no i
don't think so
we've talked about it my dad and i are
super close and uh throughout a lot of
the stuff that happens to us as children
if you want to have your family or
somebody in your life you either forgive
them
which accept how they are or accept how
they are and i've done the latter i've
just accepted it my dad and i were able
to talk i mean i became who he wanted me
to become
it's like your job is done you don't
have to teach me more [ __ ] like you
don't got to be mean you don't gotta
yell at me you don't gotta do that no
more yeah
you won graduated went to school
no babies i'm working i take care of
myself like
you've i've only had to call you a
couple times because i [ __ ] up
but look it you did good so now i'm over
here just dreaming about treyson's dicks
because of you dad
[ __ ] that my dad would tell me to go
date him my dad is so pro date
like go out there go out there date
where the [ __ ] was that when you were
younger huh
that's so interesting right because i
don't think like
like i mentioned this before but you
know just keep that story short like i
had a moment with my father where this
is like the last fight that we had it
was like four years ago like we haven't
fought since
so it was like this understanding of
like
like i've i kind of had this idea that
one day that he would apologize for the
stuff that he did
right you believe that i was like he's
gonna he's gonna see right because he's
his son's successful he's doing his own
thing
and he's gonna see the fallacy in how he
chose to raise me right and then the
stuff that he decided
he didn't want me to do that i did
anyways and i became successful doing it
right
because his idea of my life was that he
wanted me to be
this straight a student does really well
in school or whatever
knowing how i am as a person he just
chose to ignore that it's like i'm a
goofball which a part of it's right
because i am a business owner which is
he
which is kind of the path that he
thought i was going to do which he was
technically right because you know
like i look at where we're at yeah you
know much of franchise and all sorts of
stuff so
it's like okay but i remember this
moment where he had this
he we had a conversation and he said
yeah like i i
always knew that you were going to be
successful in this type of stuff because
you know i'm the reason why this this
you're so good at what you do
they take credit yeah and i stopped and
i looked at him i was like
no that's not it you know i was like i
remember i did this stuff in spite of
you
like that like you know what i mean i
did that
to prove you wrong it wasn't this was
because you supported me yeah right
and he was like what are you talking
about my desk is the funniest [ __ ] and
this this this is actually it's funny
now but
i got so mad because he was like you
don't remember when i told you
that if you wanted to be a comedian i
sent you to comedy college and i'm like
dad what the [ __ ] is comedy college
right i'm like there's no such thing
that's
comedy college you [ __ ] you jack-jack
straight a's a comedy colleague i
support you
and so he was like there's no there's
there's no comedy college
okay so he shows me the theater program
in stanford
st no he do oh your dad is like that
like dad
wow i have to get into stanford
who am i like what are you talking about
there's a comedy card [ __ ] you know
he's screaming right
so i'm just sitting there and then we
got into this huge fight
and like the one of the things that i
said to him was like you have never
ever had a conversation with me i was
like you're very good at speaking to me
but you're never good at
having a conversation with me i was in
my whole life you've always told me how
to do things when to do things
you never said you did a good job you
never said thank you you never said i'm
sorry
i was like you want us to have a good
relationship try talking to me like a
person
and he says something very poignant and
he was like i have never done that with
anybody in my life
yeah and i was like it's not going to
start with you he was like your
your grandparents your grandma and
grandpa never spoke to me that way
and i'm only a better version of them i
was like and i know that i'm
very similar to them and i was like the
difference between me and you and them
is that you think you're so much better
than me and i know that i'm not better
than my parents
so he goes so i'm not gonna change i
don't have a willingness to change
right i don't think what i'm doing is
wrong this is just how i am so at this
point if you don't understand that i'm
62 years old right because i think i'm a
[ __ ] change
if you think that i'm well i did the
best that i could he goes this is my
best
if you can't accept me for that then
who's right here yeah and i was like oh
i'm wrong i'm a little wrong right now
because he i'm asking for empathy for
him but i won't empathize for him as
well
so at that point i was like i get it
yeah i'm not gonna have like this
you know the seventh heaven [ __ ] you
know how you doing son
how are you feeling it's not going to
happen my dad's going to come in he's
going to say
hey you did this wrong right do better
next time are you hungry
and this is that is how it is i got
lucky
because i forgave my dad i felt like
there was a lot of things that happened
that he did that really [ __ ] me up
that i had to learn how to work through
and i did things
because of how i was raised and i had to
unlearn a lot of habits
yeah and i remember cons like my dad and
i
even throughout all the madness and the
craziness my dad
drove me till i was 18. i didn't get my
license until i was 18. my dad
yeah i didn't drive till i was 18.
everything he
he would always say anything you ever
need i can do for you i had to stay at
home dad
yo let me tell you something now right i
don't know if you relate to this [ __ ]
but that's so [ __ ] fun did you say
this [ __ ]
my dad used to piss me off because like
he would get
angry at me for not knowing how to do
things when he would do everything for
me
and i would get pissed it's like well
you don't let me do [ __ ] like let me do
[ __ ] yeah then i would know how to do it
you can't yell at me for both things oh
it doesn't make sense
everything was a learning lesson though
with my dad so like i said i use the
word that i've been
trained my whole life because that's
what it was i was trained
like when it comes to okay so we had a
house full of
big ass hungry horns okay so the job got
a clean
everything certain you know everybody
got chores you got things you gotta
clean
and rice was like this rice is the
foundation in the staple of
every asian mix asian whatever type of
asian island
household rice is the foundation and if
you
[ __ ] up the rice they're gonna [ __ ] you
up yeah
okay and one of the things that would
always happen is that my
dad everything was a lesson so i
was raised with lessons i didn't get the
oh you don't know how to do it because
you didn't
you don't know how to do it because i
didn't show you it was i [ __ ] showed
you how to do it
why don't you know how to do it right
away or why can't you just know what i'm
thinking
yeah so like when groceries would come
in because a big house there's a lot of
groceries one of the things was i always
had to carry all the rice bags
multiple rice bags every week you know
the rose rice i'm carrying the rice damn
that bag was [ __ ] heavy
so i would carry that bag i would carry
like two bags at a time right so
everything was like a training because
i'm conditioning them
way stronger than me i could only hold
one i was like i was like one bag that's
all i got no dad would be like carry
both of them yeah let me show you how to
carry
like everything was always like that but
let me tell you
that if [ __ ] wasn't right after you do
it it was
it was it was a catastrophe yeah and the
reason why
i forgive my dad was because i know how
my grandpa was
and my dad was the oldest and the way my
grandpa treated my dad was how my dad
treated me
rules very strict my dad had to be home
before the lights came on
uh he would get taken out of practice
for [ __ ] uh papa used to
drink so papa was an alcoholic so a lot
of crazy [ __ ] and if anybody has grown
up with alcoholic parents
you like not just oh they like to drink
occasionally but like full-blown
alcoholics in the morning drinks yes
when you grow up sleep drinks right meal
drink yeah when people don't show up for
three days like just go missing or [ __ ]
happens like
when you grow up around people like that
their behaviors are normal to them
but not normal to anybody else and if
you're living in that world you become
accustomed to that type of
treatment so you never know what's gonna
happen so you always gotta be ready
you just gotta know and that's where
i realized later on in life like my papa
[ __ ] up my dad
like their relationship my dad just
really wanted to be close to his dad
and i loved my grandpa my grandpa passed
away and i saw
how hurt my dad was by his dad never
understanding him or never being sorry
or you know always picking on it my
grandpa picked on my dad until he died
yeah i remember that and so i told my
dad i said i don't want to be like you
i don't want our relationship to be that
way i don't want to hate you
i mean our parents are just a better
version of their parents before that
totally
so they're you know they can only do so
much and i'm going to be a little better
version of my father
i just knew i saw the hurt in my dad's
eyes
and i'm so close to my dad my dad writes
me poetry like i'm my dad's
hip child i'm his little star so when i
see my dad hurt it makes me
so sad and i just hated that he
was treating me the way his dad treated
him i remember as an adult after you
know i'm already grown this is not
happening while i'm in high school
or when i'm living with them this is
what this was really like i have the
option to never talk to you again
yeah and i don't want that and i know
why you are the way you are
but i love you so you need to like you
need to knock some of this [ __ ] off
really i you know at one point i told my
dad like you got to knock it off
you make me not want to come home i want
to come home
i love you yeah so i remember after that
it became
as adults my dad looked at me different
and i always told him i said hey
i plan on taking care of you forever you
always gonna be good you're like my best
friend
but you keep doing [ __ ] like your dad
did and i'm not gonna let you do that no
more
yeah stop it papa's gone you know like
stop it i don't want to feel like you i
don't want to be mad at you when it's
too late
we're going to work on this now so that
we don't have to do that
and the way our family works now my mom
will straight up be like
baby i miss you like our relationship is
like i have a mom and dad now
yeah i didn't have a mom and dad growing
up i had parents
i have i think there's also stems
because like it seems like every single
move that they made and their motive was
to make sure
that you were going to be good and
successful because they didn't want to
see
the same tropes that everybody fell
through in hawaii yes because you know
people having kids at a young age doing
all the stupid [ __ ] so
they're trying so hard to be so much
better than what they were before
that they've kind of forgotten to be
like a friend
like somebody that you could confide
into they just wanted to set these rules
yeah you know also too like i gotta say
and a lot of people don't understand
this it's like
when you're [ __ ] poor your life is
stressed like
every day it's hard like you're like
your parents romantic relationships
become a side story they don't have a
romantic voice i was like what is a
romantic relationship
when tim brought up his parents yeah
that's what i'm saying they have a
romantic relationship doesn't exist
didn't know what that was it was a
partnership i was taught
they were partners and i was telling
this too it's like you know i started to
understand a little bit more
like some people can't understand why
people who you know didn't grow up with
a lot they they whoop their kids
uh a lot yeah and the reason why is
because they don't have time to speak to
their kids
they're too busy working they're too
busy whether there's gonna be food on
the table there's two they're too busy
trying to figure the light's gonna be on
they're finding with their spouse
things become stressed it's like there's
like i forgot what the stat is but
there's an actual stat to show like
the level of like domestic and violence
and like all this type of trouble
increases with less money
right like when you're stressed out
about [ __ ] just getting by
that idea of having this time to sit and
talk to your kid for three hours about
why they're doing things it's
not there yeah like my parents were
working like 80 hours a week and i was
there working with them too i saw that
[ __ ] we were all exhausted
so that i did so we didn't have time
they just knew that look this kid's
gonna [ __ ] up
i'm i'ma sock them real quick you know
so they know that if they do this
they'll get sucked
they don't know about the psychology
behind these things because they're not
having the time to read that [ __ ] no
they just know that if this hurts them
they'll stop
hopefully and that's about it you know
it's just
the like time is luxury like money
creates opportunities
for a lot of different things aside from
just getting you know stuff that you
like
it also allows for people to relax yeah
like my parents started
becoming better stuff and started
fighting less when our business started
doing better of course
right convenient right yeah you see how
it's how that works
yeah so when people say like i always
say this too money isn't everything to
me right
it really a hundred percent everybody
knows about me like i could give a [ __ ]
less like when people tell me they got
dope [ __ ] i could [ __ ] give a [ __ ]
less
yeah right but i do understand the the
comfort that money allows
like when i say i don't care about money
i'm talking about i don't like to live
lavishly
right but i like to live comfortably of
course and so these are the things that
are important because i know what it's
like to struggle with money it causes
fights it causes trouble
when you are worried about your meal the
next day everything is in disarray yeah
like you get you're just
stressed the [ __ ] out yeah you know i'm
super thankful that i had
my my mom busted her ass like what
gender roles
uh a lot of people think is normal i
didn't grow up around right yeah
with my mom yeah i had a stay-at-home
dad my dad raised me
my dad everything and always let me know
he would do
anything for me i play travel balls two
thousand dollars a season they believed
in me i
i i can't be ungrateful
because i've never dealt with the
adversity from home
yeah you know how some people have to
grow up and they have to prove their
parents wrong
yeah that's not what i grew up with i
grew up with supportive parents and
people around me that truly believed and
saw me
that i was gonna go somewhere and i
always had the chip on the shoulder that
i need
to live up to it yeah mama the
ex-opposite let me tell you something my
dad you had the money
my dad my dad was like listen you gotta
work at this store because you're dumb
as [ __ ]
like you're not gonna make a living i'll
tell you this my dad
let me tell you this one day so i did
radio so my parents still live in newman
like
that's where we moved to they live right
around the corner from the house that i
grew up in right
like they own their home small small
cute little home this they're still
there
and the radio station that i always want
on kwin plays in the valley so 997 um
it's out there in the valley 98.3 and i
did the morning show
and my parents i mean my dad is a proud
[ __ ] dad let me tell you he has my
maxim
my swimsuit maxim magazine calendar
like he would keep in his car this is my
daughter yes
and he would do it because he loved
watching guys get nervous so my dad like
thinks it's the funniest thing when
people find out he's my dad he loves it
but my parents are super super super
supportive and they tuned in and they
listen and everybody's listening but i
remember one day
um i had gotten off at air and we had a
segment called uh
dear nikki yeah where people would write
in about
problems questions issues now i get a
phone call from my dad
and my dad goes hey what'd you
study in school it's like uh you know i
just kind of
just kind of went in general why he goes
you know you know i love you right
he's like yes he goes i never knew you
was smart i was like what
oh the way you wouldn't say all that
that was real good like
you should go go finish school like go
school for psychology like wow you real
you real smart like baby that was really
good i tell you that was the first time
that i realized that my dad didn't think
i was smart growing up like
that's so [ __ ] funny wait hold on a
second dad you thought i was stupid yes
it's like that's why you play baseball
goddammit he
literally said i always knew you
you were gonna be okay but
we knew you modeled that's so [ __ ]
but when you got into radio they were a
little bit like
so you want them to just listen to you
like like why you're pretty
you're pretty you're smart you're smart
in the sense of knowing how to do that
like
they knew like being in front of the
camera was gonna be cake they're like
you good
so when i got into radio i'm pretty sure
my parents went
i don't know if you should be making
that left over there because you're
gonna
you're taking away from the money maker
but that day i remember sitting in my
car in the complex that i was at i just
got off air and when he told me that i
died laughing i was like holy [ __ ] you
thought i was stupid he goes
we knew you were pretty and we always
knew you were gonna probably
marry well that's [ __ ] funny dude
it's like it's like the sweetest most
biggest insult
ever and to this day that was a moment
to where i was like wow
i love you guys but [ __ ] you
everybody like overall my whole family
because i'm the dork i'm goofy i
definitely was
the like it wasn't all there like all
the pieces
didn't connect and everybody kind of
knew that
i knew i was dorky and but i didn't know
people didn't think i was smart they
just knew i just like to talk a lot
but it's just like oh nikki just likes
to talk and that was the first time
though i was like you guys [ __ ]
actually
listen to me and now it's cool i just
bet your dad it's like
you know how to read i was like yo what
the [ __ ] man dad was like
because i took a lot of uh honors
classes like they knew i was smart
right like i took all the i was smart
but they didn't know that it would
translate into like logic right they
knew
i was book smart but that's why my dad
trained me the way he did because he was
worried he was like you a little ditzy
like you
you're gonna take you're gonna be taken
advantage of so my dad always
pumped all that stuff into me so that i
wouldn't get taken advantage of
so when i did that that day and i
started doing um the advice segment with
dear nicki he was like
you're actually really like you're
really like you know things
yeah you know things oh you listen
that's where he kind of went oh [ __ ] you
actually
did hear me when i was giving you
lessons growing up
and my dad is always my example for so
many things the reason why i have a
career in speaking is because of the
[ __ ] he put me through
yeah yeah the good the bad the ugly i
love my family but that's my
that's where my values come from and
where i speak from because i've gone
through a lot of [ __ ]
and when you go through a lot of stuff
you can empathize with people right
and then if you could learn how to
articulate those things and
translate it like you can actually help
people
so he heard that and was like oh [ __ ]
full circle moment i just find it so
funny your dad just can't like
what you go to school for yeah
yeah that's [ __ ] funny now my dad was
like oh i remember you in class
oh man that's so [ __ ] i never know
what you wouldn't go to school for i
just know you was there at least that
girl you're smart my dad still hasn't
called me smart yeah
you know your boy smart you jackass you
would love i feel like
i brag about my parents a lot because
that's they're just dope i think my dad
is one of the coolest people i've ever
met i think my mom
is strong as [ __ ] like her and i didn't
have a relationship till
i was old enough to understand what she
had to sacrifice to get me where
i am well that takes time and age like
when i always tell like these kids who
ask advice for their parents it's like
i could i could tell you everything like
the right answers
you're not gonna know until you get
older because you just haven't lived
that life it you don't
you can't empathize with stuff that you
haven't experienced you can't relate
they have no idea they don't know what
struggle is like you said like most
people don't know what it is to be poor
like poor poor like we're not talking
about
oh i just didn't have the newest shoes
it's like no like
like poor like i lived in a house with
13 people we had
wick we had food stamps back when it was
brown paper i remember my aunt
buying the food stamps from my mom for
cash like that's the type of [ __ ] that
we grew up around purple drink
if you don't know what purple drink or
government cheese is you don't know
hang baby tang that's nice y'all had a
tank yeah
you remember the little packets that
were like uh five cents a packet
and then making that but that was water
pops
we but you know what my parents always
our family because there was a lot of us
that raised us it wasn't just mom and
dad
we had a lot of adults that raised us oh
we always knew
our position in life we knew we was poor
they never pretended like
we had more than what we had you know we
always knew
but the goal always was this isn't
it this isn't how you're supposed to
live
my parents always reminded this ain't
normal
you're gonna be better you're gonna go
to school you're gonna learn finances my
grandma put me up on finances real real
young my mom taught me about credit
cards
real real young i never i always never
needed anybody
and they always made sure i mean your
parents did a really great job
none of that [ __ ] they're just like
you're good though they're like you
figured it out
you know at work though look at where
you are like everybody's motives are
different
and it didn't work for a long time i
felt there was a big space in me
a very big hole a lot of resentment a
lot of hurt a lot of pain
and my sister used to tell my dad you
[ __ ] her up like there i had real
issues with a lot of things
getting in i didn't know how to be an
individual
i had no idea what that meant i was told
to play ball
yeah i was told i needed to do this
somebody dictated my life till i was
done with sports
mind you nobody really talks about the
effects on uh on a female athlete
my whole life has been i've been told
what to do and then i have to learn how
to do things
like these male athletes they get [ __ ]
right they don't know what to do with
their money they don't know what to do
with their time don't know what to do
when you see these fighters
like specifically fighters boxers
kickboxers
ufc fighters their whole identity is
about
knocking people out and winning when you
take that away from them and that
usually happens because of age
and it's not something that due to their
own issues it's just you just got old
it's one of the hardest things to deal
with because your whole identity was
built
on doing this one [ __ ] task that's it
and you didn't have anything else
besides either the belt that you were
looking for the trophy
or the goals and that was it yeah yeah
finding yourself a lot of athletes are
great at what they do
because that's all they have to do and
everybody around them
makes it comfortable for them to do
those things the finances everything
everything
right as long as i do well things are
taken care of i had a balance because i
had to earn my spot because financially
we couldn't just afford to be in these
places
so i had to work 10 times harder than
anybody else and i had no idea who i was
what i wanted
if you know when i was done playing
sports you could ask me what i'd like to
do for fun i don't know
i didn't know like sports i'm just doing
dips like watching this tv that's all
i'm doing i train
i love to win i'm competitive uh you
give me a task
i have to accomplish it i have certain
tendencies of
only athletes that want to be the best
at everything they do
get yeah somebody recently asked me why
can't you just do something for fun
i said winning is fun yeah
going and playing a game that i don't
know how to play i need to learn how to
play the game first
in order for it to be fun because i
don't unders i don't understand well
that's stressful as [ __ ]
stressful as [ __ ] but a lot of it stems
from my dad
dictating my whole life coaches
dictating my whole life
teachers dictating everything i'm the
opposite now i don't do that [ __ ] i just
ride my bike like a little
little like i'm it took
forever to get to a place to where i'm
doing
what i like i have a personality now
that i didn't have before
but that took time like i really didn't
know any of it and my mom always pushed
she's like break away as much as
possible
you need to figure out who the [ __ ] you
are and then my dad after a certain
point was like
you need to figure out who you are okay
my job's done
what do you like what do you not like
who are you can you actually stand up
for yourself
do you just listen to like i'm great at
listening to authority i know
i know how to do what i'm told and it
just
took so long to become this person
that throughout all of that i'm
so thankful but i know
that when i have kids one day there's
gonna be definitely gonna be things that
i don't do the same but i'm happy that
my parents i mean you'll try your best
you know oh i'm just happy that my kids
are gonna have grandparents
that love them and want you know like
want the best for them that's the one
thing at the core of all of it most kids
don't realize
some parents i wouldn't say all cause
some people shouldn't be parents period
some of you all unfortunately are being
raised by
by people who had kids they didn't know
that they were going to be parents and
it's really unfortunate
so i don't take my parents for granted
and my whole goal at the end of this is
to take care of them
yeah what motivates me is i uh i tell my
mom and dad like
you [ __ ] need to get healthy because
by the time i have a baby i'm gonna need
somebody to watch them
and you're gonna tell some hawaiian
parents to get healthy good [ __ ] luck
dude yes
i tell my dad all the [ __ ] all the
time my dad has [ __ ] gone
portuguese sausage eggs and rice are you
nuts oh my god my dad already
had like has had congestive heart
failure since i was like he got to cut
that [ __ ] out there
and and the thing is i'm the last one in
my family now to not have a kid
and i want them to be around and my mom
and dad are so dope because they know
hey whenever you're ready to have a kid
we're here to help you we want you to
contin like
we want you to know that your career
doesn't stop because you have a baby
and they're one thousand percent my mom
looks forward to the day that
they get to watch the kids when i go and
work yeah
and that's what i feel like a parenting
goal
is that like support so i don't take
them for granted that's why i'm thankful
that i forgave because if i never
forgave i would be missing out
i wouldn't i wouldn't get to experience
any of this yeah
guys that wraps up this episode of the
genius brain podcast
i mean there's so much more to talk
about i could probably talk for another
eight hours
but she gotta fly and we gotta eat so uh
where can they find you uh everywhere at
nikki blades
no just for real thank you for having me
well i wanted to be here for so long you
know what they call genius brain man
called genius brain therapy well you
guys can find nicki blades at everywhere
nikki blaze
uh she just dropped merch not too long
ago so make sure you guys cop that you
can catch her on the no chaser podcast
you can see her on the radios in the
morning
and then all you other guys just
continue to jack off to her photos
you guys are already doing it anyways
every thursday sunday's genius brain
podcast we'll see you next time
peace bye